elle vous est excité ou pas l'art fait
vous êtes excité ou pas il m'avait l'air
trop excité je vous ai mis une image
pour vous des excités rigolez pas c'est
là où j'ai grandi et je me barre là j'ai
grandi là bas que j'ai une vie très
excitante sert hlm et ma grand mère
habitait au 11e étage ça vous allez vous
coucher moins bête ce soir pas le genre
de truc que vous vous attendiez à
prendre dans un tête j'imagine ça
sortira pas de votre tête
la grand mère d'idriss aberkane habitait
au 11e étage de cette tour
pourquoi je vous demande ça ce que je
suis persuadé en fait que dans le monde
qui nous entoure
tous les objets concret nous êtres
humains et qui nous entoure eh bien ils
peuvent parler on peut leur demander
pourquoi ils sont là tous les objets
qu'on a créée et dont on est responsable
et qui font notre quotidien qui font
notre environnement
on peut leur demander petit objet petits
petits produits petit service pourquoi
tu es là et je suis convaincu que si on
demandait vraiment aux objets qui nous
entourent pourquoi ils sont là l'immense
majorité nous répondrait je suis là
parce qu'un marché connard vérifiez-le
sur les objets qui vous entourent la
plupart des objets sont là juste parce
qu'il ya un marché
d'ailleurs les gens qui les ont
fabriqués les utilise pas elle même les
gens qui ont fait sept tours il n'y
vivent pas non et puis il ya d'autres
objets qu'ils disent pas celui-là parce
qu'un marché et et là on a des objets
qui on se demande même pourquoi ils sont
là au départ sept tours par exemple ma
grand mère y a pas vécu c'était la plus
haute tour de la chrétienté pendant très
longtemps un cathédrale de strasbourg
tout ça mais là on est sur un objet si
on lui demande pourquoi tu es là petit
bâtiment là il va répondre je suis là
parce que papa et maman cm très fort et
ça c'est les objets d'exception que ce
soit des produits des biens des services
mais ça peut aussi être des bâtiments
genre l'opéra de sydney la tour eiffel
la tour eiffel qui devait être démonté
qui servait à rien demandé à la tour
eiffel pourquoi tu es là
je suis là parce que papa et maman cm
très fort c'est pas rationnel si on
avait fait un business plan on l'aurait
pas fait je suis là pour vous parler de
ça en fait de ce qui fait la
particularité de ted en général pourquoi
t'es dit aussi spécial
on va voir qu'en fait c'est précisément
la passion et l'amour
mais avant ça je vais vous parler d'un
truc qui parlera pas forcément les rexie
temps là tout de suite on est en train
de réaliser une transaction de
connaissances suis en train de vous
donner de la connaissance si vous êtes
en train de me donner deux chose en
échange
lesquels qu'est ce que vous me donnez là
maintenant tout de suite de la tension
pour l'amour on va y revenir et et du
temps en fait si vous voulez acheter de
la connaissance il faut payer en
attention et en temps c'est l'équation
que j'ai découverte à standford elle
mord pas vous inquiétez pas elle est
très gentille elle décrit ce que vous
allez faire aujourd'hui chez ted vous
allez donner de l'attention et du temps
au speaker pour acheter de la
connaissance il faut payer en attention
x du temps vérifiant que c'est bien un
produit d'ailleurs le produit ça veut
dire que si l'un des 2 0 le tout vos
héros bon si vous me donnez une heure de
votre temps mais pendant une heure vous
êtes en mode musique d'ascenseur dans
votre tête n'ira pas beaucoup d'
échanges de connaissances qu'on veut on
sent bien qu'il faut vous me donniez
toute votre attention et tout votre
temps et bien ça c'est la monnaie de
l'économie de la connaissance pour
apprendre quelque chose il faut payer
avec de la tension et du temps et la
bonne nouvelle dans cette équation c'est
que tout le monde à de la tension et du
temps à la naissance oui le petit
somalien il est pas né avec 1000 $ en
poche mais il a de la tension et du
temps à la naissance donc l'économie de
la connaissance
c'est la seule économie où tout le monde
est né avec du pouvoir d'achat ce qui
est quand même une bonne nouvelle mais
dans quelles conditions on donne toute
notre attention et tout notre temps à
quelqu'un comment ça s'appelle ça
l'amour quand vous aimez quelqu'un vous
lui donner toute votre attention et tout
votre temps sans compter l'économie de
la connaissance est la seule économie
qui maximise le pouvoir d'achat des
amoureux littéralement
si vous voulez apprendre plus vite fait
d'abord en sorte de tomber amoureux de
la connaissance que vous allez apprendre
alors l'histoire de mon travail et de
mes découvertes tourne autour de ça quel
est le rôle de l'amour dans l'économique
est censé être un truc un peu prosaïque
et à standford quand j'en parlais les
gens comprenaient assez bien mais en
france quand je disais bon parlons un
peu d'amour dans les entreprises sans
déconner les gens comprenaient pas alors
je leur disais quand même pour maximiser
le flux de connaissances il faut adorer
ce qu'on fait faites en sorte d'adorer
votre job c'est le plus important vous
verrez que vous serez compétitif comme
ça mais apparemment j'avais toujours pas
trouvé la bonne formule surtout chez les
managers
j'enseigne à centrale ses cadres et
voiliers alors je me suis dit bon on est
au pays de descartes on va faire un
diagramme faire un truc bien cartésien
comme il faut j'ai appelé ça love can do
et je suis dit bon qu'est ce que c'est
que les entreprises un peu différente un
peu au dessus de la mêlée c'est celle
qui savent ce qu'ils font ce qu'elles
savent faire pardon je suis dit on va
mettre sur un axe can do est ce que sait
faire mon job mais on va rajouter un
autre axe et on va rester dans un bon
diagramme cartésien bien comme il faut
et on va mettre du lover vous me
pardonnerez de mettre l'amour dans un
diagramme cartésien et puis là on va se
dire bon classement un peu les boîtes ou
pas que les entreprises d'ailleurs un
toute initiative selon que les gens font
ce qu'ils aiment et ce qu'ils savent
faire
alors la boîte qui fait ce qu'elle aime
et ce qu'elle sait faire c'est la boîte
au dessus de la mêlée et au dessus de la
mêlée ça veut pas dire leader ça veut
dire y'a vous il ya le reste du monde
typiquement site apple au dessus de la
mêlée ça veut dire quoi
chris martin et gwyneth paltrow est une
fille chris martin le chanteur de
coldplay gwyneth paltrow
la star hollywoodienne ils ont une fille
comment ils l'appellent apple qui va
appeler sa fille samsung
donc c'est ça au dessus de la mêlée
c'est voilà ça fait rigoler parce que
c'est au-dessus de la mêlée quoi alors
après il ya le suiveur dire que le
suiveur il fait bien son job il le
connaît il le gère mais l'amour il s'en
fout et là vous allé m'excuser mais
samsung ils sont pas passés des
toilettes aux tablettes parce qu'ils
adoraient ça il y avait un marché quand
le marché était là ils y sont allés
l'immense majorité des entreprises c'est
ça il ya un marché givet points
ça c'est le suiveur la différence entre
le suiveur et le leader le type au
dessus de la mêlée c est ce que je fais
le job parce que j'aime ça ou est-ce que
ce fait le job juste parce que il ya un
marché à propos de job vous connaissez
la petite blague
on dit que les américains en steve jobbs
et en france on à pôle emploi
il n'y a pas de montage en tedx un
boulot c'est pour vous c'est pour moi
après on ad'autres d'autres acteurs mois
celui que j'aime bien c'est le garage de
la silicon valley toutes ces boîtes qui
se sont créés dans des garages qu'est ce
que ça veut dire le fait qu'elle soit là
c'est à dire la ola ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire love maximum et savoir-faire
minimum google séné comme ça amazon ce
n'est comme ça tesla séné comme ça apple
sait mais comme sahin hewlett packard
disney oui disney il a monté alice au
pays des merveilles dans un garage à los
angeles
cherchez pas de jeu de mots soient les
gentils
deuxième degré quand tu nous tiens les
garage de la silicon valley il se lance
dans un métier non pas parce qu'ils
savent le faire ils n'y connaissent rien
par contre ils adorent ça et le garage
ça va sélectionner ceux qui adorent ça
parce que un garage ya pas de notes ya
pas de prix vous aurez pas un prix
régional de compétitivité machin vous
n'aurez rien vous êtes dans un garage
vous pouvez pas aller draguer une nana
au bar et chérissent bois dans un garage
nom et sur votre cv vous pouvez
permettre je bosse dans un garage ya
aucune récompense ni notes ni diplôme ya
que ce que vous faites et le garage sa
seleccion les amateurs les passionnés du
job
ceux qui adorent ça et du coup quand
vous mélanger amour et incompétence et
bien vous avez les faits désolé les mecs
je savais pas que c'était impossible
donc je les fais et ça c'est typique des
boîtes de la silicon valley qui sont nés
dans un garage pendant que nous on était
là à leur dire hey les mecs c'est
impossible
eux ils l'ont fait parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas les manuels pour les
brider après le plus grave évidemment
c'est qu'on a des joueurs qui sont là
les entrants forcé alors eu bon c'est
très simple à résumer c'est des mecs on
leur demande pourquoi tu fais ton boulot
pourquoi tu fais tes produits bas c'est
parce qu'il fallait bien moi je voulais
de veto au départ mais on m'a dit fais
ce produit je le fais est le meilleur
exemple c'est la marque lada que vous
avez peut-être connu ou les motos russes
aussi en général j'ai un très bon ami
qui a rencontré un marabout en afrique
et donc comme tous les marabouts il
avait la liste de ces grands miracles
retour de l'être aimé amour gloire
beauté guérison des ongles incarnés tout
ça et son argument de finition c'était
démarre même les motos russe donc il ya
marcher sur l'eau et ya démarré les
motos russe quoi donc ça vous en dit
long sur les motos russe est clairement
baramoto russell fait pas rêver quoi
alors voilà une fois qu'on a ce petit
diagramme on peut voir que s'ils
suiveurs il veut passer au dessus de la
mêlée il a qu'une seule question à se
poser
et là vous verrez leur accord est
magnifique avec le thème de ce tête sens
ascensionnels auto cohérence dans s'en
voulait un peu
ils doivent poser la question why
pourquoi je fais mon job lente renforcée
par contre alors la flèche en rouge en
bas là ça c'est la voie de la souffrance
parce que là vous acquérez le savoir
faire sans avoir envie de faire le job
donc là vous êtes en mode bon pourquoi
tu travailles pas parce qu'il faut bien
et là c'est la souffrance et le suicide
au travail c'est l'enfer le garage de la
silicon valley au contraire lui il
acquiert toute sa connaissance par amour
lui fait le job parce qu'ils adorent ça
et toute son expertise il va l'acquérir
sur la voie de l'amour
cette voie là je les appelais el camino
real qui est le nom de l'avenue de la
silicon valley la grande avenue qui
structure la silicon valley s'appelle la
voie royale en espagnol el camino real
et c'est comme ça que j'ai appelé cette
transition
parce que les google les apple les walt
disney les hewlett-packard ont suivi
cette voie et ce qu'ils ont le mieux
suivi et qui illustre parfaitement le
love can do c'était cela tesla c'est
typiquement la boîte qui n'y
connaissaient rien par rapport à ses
concurrents mais rien de rien et du coup
pratiquement toutes les décisions qui
ont été prises étaient complètement
débiles dans cette dans cette boîte
complètement irrationnel sur ce châssis
là vous avez le love can do illustré sur
cette photo vous avez le love et le
kendo le love c'est ça c'est ce moteur
en fait quand elon musk crette cela il
demande à ses ingénieurs d'avoir un
moteur qui a été inventé par nikola
tesla parce qu'il est fan de nikola
tesla c'est le léonard de vinci du xxème
siècle il dit à ses ingénieurs
moi je veux qu'il ya un moteur inventé
par nikola tesla mais si vous y
réfléchissez bien c'est comme demander à
airbus d'avoir une technologie léonard
de vinci c'est débile et donc les
ingénieurs lui dise bas c'est débile et
la noise dit non non vous n'avez pas
compris c'est moi qui sors
artiche donc vous allez me faire un
moteur nikola tesla vous la fermez bien
comme il faut ce moteur qui fait faire
des nuits blanches à tout
l'establishment automobile mondial c'est
un moteur qui a été breveté par nikola
tesla en 1896 donc ça c'est du loft
parce que vous prenez pas cette décision
rationnellement rationnellement on va
battre nos concurrents avec un machin
qui datent du 19e non c'est juste parce
que je suis passionné de tesla
donc ça doit être là et le can do c'est
la batterie ici alors là vous voyez pas
les batteries mais elles vont être posés
sur ce châssis et le can do c'était bon
bah une bagnole avec des batteries on
n'avait pas des très bons rendements
alors allez de masse dit attendez un
ordinateur portable ça une bonne
batterie ouais c'est pas mal oui il ya
les nouveaux mac qui sont sortis de ça
ils avaient des bonnes batterie à
l'époque bon bah très bien vous allez me
prendre des batteries de mac et vous
allez les empiler et c'est ça qu'ils ont
fait love can do dans la même alors le
summum du love can do mais on va pas s'y
attarder ça sera une interprète si vous
vous laissez les frères wright les
frères wright c'est du love can do à
tous les étages du die pas de diplôme
les mecs le dire pendant que des gars à
polytechnique ou et mighty à la royal
society chercher à faire voler le
premier avion ce qu'ils ont fait voler
le premier avion s'était 2 clampins qui
n'avais pas le bac à 60 km de dayton
dans l'ohio
pourquoi parce qu'ils se crashait cinq
fois par jour il ya un très bon tête
speaker qui l'a dit bien mieux que moi
qui s'appelle simon sinek vous passez
une minute avec symons n'est que ça
vaudra mieux que mon tête de maintenant
je vous le dis sans aucun complexe
sérieusement simons hayek la conclusion
du love can do pour moi c'est simplement
que dans n'importe quelle expertise vous
avez vu attention x le temps est bien
quand vous apprenez quelque chose votre
cours d'apprentissage si vous êtes
passionné uniquement si vous êtes
passionné va suivre ces grandes étapes 5
55 105000 peut-être 50 milles en heure
en cinq heures vous rentrez dans
n'importe quelles connaissances en 50
heures vous êtes autonome en 500 heures
vous pouvez l'enseigné en 5000 heures on
a les premiers prix nobel et en
cinquante mille heures on à ce que les
japonais appellent le trésor national
vivant
j'insiste pour vous dire que ça ne
marche que si vous apprenez par passion
si on est à attention maximale et je
vais vous montrer un cas d'un trésor
national vivant
wallace chan le meilleur bijoutier au
monde
ce type là il est vraiment au dessus de
la mêlée et ce type là il a 100 miller
dans ce qu'il fait c'est exceptionnel
aucun bijoutier ne sait faire comme lui
j'aime ont juste une de ses réalisations
qui montre le love can do le type a fait
un portrait dans une aide marine
ça s'appelle la voilà ce que tu es il
arrive à couper un portrait qui se
réfléchit sur toutes les facettes de la
marine pourquoi uniquement parce qu'ils
adorent ça et qu'il ne prend pas de
vacances parce que lui quand on lui
demande est ce que tu veux prendre des
vacances est dit mais je suis déjà en
vacances dans mon atelier je suis déjà
en vacances ya que ça qui m'épanouit
aujourd'hui vous allez voir plein de
speaker qui vont illustrer bien mieux
que moi le love can do parce que moi je
vous en parle d'un point de vue
théorique et eux vont vous en parlez
d'un point de vue pratique le speaker
qui vient juste après moi va vous parler
du love dans l'entreprise et là vous
allez voir exactement ce que le love can
do peut donner
et ainsi de suite pour les vieilles
charrues et c'est tout ce que je veux
que vous fassiez maintenant c'est que
vous considériez le love can do dans
votre vie et vous vous disiez au final
quelque chose d'extrêmement simple qui
est que tout homme économiquement utile
n'est pas forcément épanouie mais tout
homme épanoui et forcément
économiquement utile alors mettons
l'épanouissement avant l'utilité
économique
excellente journée à vous